so it's an all-star lineup that part of
the prime time special tomorrow night
celebrating the inauguration of joe
biden and kamala harris
yeah yeah now country stars usually try
to stay out of politics
but tim mcgraw and taylor hubbard will
perform their new song
undivided and garth brooks is going to
perform as well
here is what garth had to say about
making that decision
unity loving one another man that's kind
of what you spent your time doing and as
a singer that's what you get to sing
about
so uh this is a great day uh in our
household
this is not a political statement this
is a statement of unity the
invitation that i accepted before and
accepting now
is the president of the united states
that's it it's it's not republican or
democrat
it's a leader for whom i am a civilian
of the greatest country on the planet
so it is our leader so our
job is to work as hard as we can for all
to have a better future than before
and here's the great thing is you can
have the greatest future in the world
in the last 10 years 20 years our job as
human beings is to make the next
four years 10 years better than that i
might be the only republican
at this place but it's reaching across
loving one another because that's what's
going to get us
through probably the most divided times
that we have
and i i mean i couldn't say it better i
love that he is reaching across the
aisle
and i love the fact that he is saying
that it's not political for him
he simply wants to serve his country and
he wants to
salute the office of the president of
the united states so i'm all for that
yeah and it's been four years since
somebody's been able to say that you
know for the past four years
an artist couldn't say an artist
couldn't say i don't care
you know who it is this is the president
asking me and i want to serve the
country you couldn't say that for the
past four years
uh i like garth brooks and i and i like
that i like garth brooks over the last
sort of couple of years even when he
backed out of contention for
artist of the year um you know with
those awards like he's just
he is always relevant but yet so
relatable like as huge as garth brooks
is because he's reached heights that
very few artists have garth brooks has
this thing
that makes him just relatable to the
people that love him
and it's messages like this that he can
put across
better than a lot of people oh yeah
definitely and the fact that he's a
republican and truly reaching across the
aisle because as you guys know in our
political system for the last four years
democrat and republicans have been like
the hatfields and the mccoys right
so there have been there's been such a
divisive spirit
and so now i love that the republican is
coming to play for a democratic
president
yeah darlene says garth brooks the best
human ever i adore him
jesus says well said garth our bernie
says i love garth republicans in idaho
are already boycotting guards
uh jk says i think garth brooke is
showing how to be a republican not a
trump fanatic so
uh good for him uh agents as being
united should be the standard but yeah
baby ask you first do you think garth is
going to get backlash from this or do
you think what he said about unity there
is going to smooth things over because
remember trump supporters were fine with
mike pence
all of a sudden last week they're ready
to hang my my pen so do you think yeah
girls brooke's naturally yeah well he's
certainly going to get backlash from
this but you know what music is a great
unifier and i think that once they
really settle into the idea
that trump is not coming back he's not
going they're not going to be able to
overturn the voters oh that's stuff
they've been saying
um once they realize that um that uh
biden harris is in there for at least
four years i think people will come
around because
he makes great music and they do love
him and so i think this is just a little
blip in the matrix
but i think they'll come back around he
won't lose fans he won't lose many fans
right yeah i listen i think that
you know both people on the the the left
you know and and the right i think that
the one thing that people can agree on
is
being angry is exhausting and i think
people
are tired of all of this and
to even have one afternoon oh my god my
cat i'm so sorry
one afternoon or
or one moment or one moment to just feel
normal
you know i would like to say that i
don't think garth is going to get a ton
of backlash
from anybody who matters no right
exactly yeah love garth love him
bringing healing and appreciate his
commitment to
united country once again i think he was
very pointed that he mentioned he's a
republican
too i think because we rarely hear a
celebrity say that especially a
republican celebrity say that
so i think that was very pointed that he
included that in
his explanation yeah yeah and there are
a lot of
problems go ahead yeah
absolutely and i agree with you and then
listen 75 or some odd million people
voted for trump
and there are people in there that were
just proud republicans and not everybody
loved the guy and not everybody would
would you know storm the capital
there's still a lot of people in america
that voted for donald trump and i think
that it's moments like this and guys
like garth brooks
that are you know maybe maybe it's time
to to pump the brakes and stop being so
angry
and find a moment and uh and hopefully
it's it's it's there's a lot more of
these these moments
well biden harris has already stated
that they're gonna be
an administration for all americans not
just for democratic americans
not just for left-leaning americans for
all americans
so garth brooks is right in line with
the current
uh presidential administration so i'm
happy
and i can't wait to see everyone perform
at the inauguration
especially jlo oh yeah
and my friend john legend's going to be
performing as well so it's going to be a
great show yeah